es ist die Nachricht des Tages die
englische Premierministerin ist nach nur
sechs Wochen im Amt zurückgetreten der
Grund sind gescheiterte Steuerpläne und
querien mit ihren Ministern und
Parteikollegen nun muss sie sich viel
Häme gefallen lassen eine britische
Boulevardzeitung hat ein Eisbergsalat
zum frische Sieger eines
durchhaltewettbewerbs gegen Trust
gekürzt ich finde hingegen man sollte
dieser Frau doch gratulieren also wenn
Menschen einem Job nicht gewachsen sind
ist es doch der einzige richtige Weg
zurückzutreten in Deutschland kommt es
mir so vor wäre solch ein Rücktritt
hingegen und denkbar man hat ja das
Gefühl dass die Spitzenpolitiker so
richtig fest an ihren Sesseln kleben
Überforderung im Amt hin oder her ein
Grund ist da für mich die
wirtschaftliche Abhängigkeit ich habe
auch einen Lösungsansatz heute abend
mitgebracht zu Debatte in die Runde wie
wäre es denn wenn wir als Gesellschaft
größere finanzielle rücktrittsanreize
schaffen wird aktuell erhalten Minister
viereinhalb monats-gelder Übergangsgeld
das ist selbstverständlich sehr viel
aber wenn ich ein manch einen Minister
denke da wäre es mir auch ein dass er
noch Gehalt bekommt oder sogar zwei
vielleicht müssen wir einfach den
finanziellen Schaden noch mehr
minimieren und damit mehr unfähige
Bundesminister aus dem Amt bekommen ich
bin gespannt wie das meine Runde hier
sieht und natürlich auch wieder
Rücktritt von Frau Trust gesehen wird
und da frage ich erstmal Carolin Bosbach
selbst sie die u-politikerin dein Vater
ist ja auch CDU-Politiker CDU Urgestein
Wolfgang Bosbach die Frage ist wie
siehst du es denn mit Rücktritten habe
ich recht liege ich falsch brauchen wir
gar keine Anreize ich sag's mal so es
ist du hast ja immer ich glaube wir
müssen unterscheiden das eine ist die
fachliche Inkompetenz oder das was wir
als solche wahrnehmen würde für mich da
bin ich tatsächlich anderer Meinung
nicht ausreichen wir müssen
unterscheiden zwischen fachlichen
versagen oder vielleicht Fehlbesetzungen
und wirklich persönlichen Fehlschlägen
Beispiel wenn man nach Österreich schaut
dann dachte ich so bei kurz damals es
war alternativlos es ging nicht anders
aber wenn du jetzt sagst du das Gefühl
hast oder den Eindruck dass die hier zu
lange an ihren Sesseln kleben auch das
würde ich tatsächlich verneinen also es
ist für mich so ein zum Beispiel was
damals mit der Wolf passiert ist das war
klar hat er einen Fehler gemacht der
doch große Fehler gemacht und das war
auch lief auch bei aller Liebe nicht
alles glatt aber diese Hetzjagd die da
auf ihn da veranstaltet worden ist wie
der gejagt worden ist von der Meute und
es überhaupt keine andere Chance für
immer gegeben hat muss ich schon sagen
ob das sein muss weiß ich nicht und ich
kann auch nur dafür waren direkt auf
alles drauf zu springen was mal jemandem
vorwirft und nicht immer alles direkt
für bare Münze zu nehmen werden wir hier
einmal ganz konkret nehmen wir mal Frau
Lambrecht unsere Verteidigungsministerin
Rücktritt ja oder nein also nochmal ich
halte sie nicht für die beste Besetzung
die wir für die von diesen Posten
irgendwie schaffen könnten es würde mir
aber unter bleibe ich auch bei nicht
reichen zu sagen mir reicht ihre
fachliche Kompetenz nicht aus deswegen
muss jetzt zurücktreten das ist mir
nicht genug kann man nicht machen
hier ist ja so ein bisschen der Punkt
Herr gersemann was braucht denn dann
eine Liste also die fachliche Kompetenz
die ist gar nicht so schlimm wenn sie
nicht da ist dann braucht man noch keine
Rücktritt ab wann müssten denn Minister
zurücktreten und wie blicken sie auf
England
naja das ist natürlich erstmal
erfrischend das was möglich ist jemand
der einen totalen Fehlstart hinten legt
wie Frau Trassen England trittern zurück
eigentlich ist ja das politische System
in Großbritannien angelegt wie ein
Diktatur auf Zeit wenn man erst mal im
Amt ist dann ist man auch sicher im
Sattel und muss eigentlich nicht um das
Amt fürchten jahrelang das ist auch
anders durchaus als das Amt des
deutschen Bundeskanzlers das sehr viel
unsicher ist also von daher was da
gerade heute passiert ist es wirklich
richtig spektakulär und das halt so ein
Fehltritt dann sozusagen auch bestraft
wird mit seinem Rücktritt ist natürlich
eben guten erfrischend in Deutschland
hat man natürlich den Eindruck ja es
kleben sehr viele Leute sehr lange an
ihren Sesseln ich wunder mich dass der
Name Schwesig noch nicht gefallen ist in
dem zusammen beispielsweise auch
zurückgetreten ja das war dann auch ein
sehr langes Leiden muss man sagen das
stimmt das stimmt also das Problem
generell scheint mir eher zu sein nicht
zu sehr die Pensionsansprüche sondern
generell Alternativen die Politiker
haben zu ihrem Politiker leben wir haben
natürlich ein ganz ganz großen Teil vom
Politikern die nie was anderes waren als
Politiker und die auch ganz anderes
können das will ich jetzt nicht sagen
wer vielleicht ein bisschen übertrieben
aber die tatsächlich nie einander
Karriere ernsthaft ins Auge gefasst
haben als die eines Berufspolitikers und
dann haben wir natürlich tatsächlich den
Anreiz unbedingt in einem politischen an
zu bleiben oder zumindest in der
politischen Fähre zu bleiben und das
nicht zu verlieren und ja da kann man
glaube ich auch Pensionen aus sich
stellen wie man will wenn man nachher
mit Mitte 40 Mitte 50 da steht und
eigentlich keine Alternative mehr hat
dann klickt man halt da machen also uns
wurde auch immer gesagt dass Kinder zu
Hause aber macht bloß nicht hier
Kreißsaal oder sagt Plenarsaal ihr geht
erstmal arbeiten und das haben wir auch
alle gemacht und das ist auch
tatsächlich ich habe das auch jahrelang
mitbekommen bei uns in der Familie Papa
immer nebenbei gearbeitet der war am
Wochenende die Sonntage in der Kanzlei
durchgearbeitet weil immer gesagt hat
kannst von heute auf morgen zur abgesagt
sein das kann sonst irgendetwas
passieren und dann fällst du sehr sehr
weich also bin ich total bei jenes fehlt
total aber er ist ja auch kein Minister
geworden
ist es ist ja auch schon fast verpönt
wenn Politiker zwischen Wirtschaft und
Politik hin und her wachsen ist das kann
ich auch nicht verstehen absolut ja du
kannst den Leuten nicht verdienen auch
nebenbei Geld zu verdienen ich weiß
nicht warum das in Deutschland ein so
schlechten Ruf hat lass uns doch froh
sein wenn ihr auch noch Kontakt zu
anderen sage ich mal
Lebenswirklichkeiten auf von behalten
und sich nicht in ihrer Blase bewegen
aber das mag auch eine Einzel Meinung
sein hör auf mal wie sehen Sie das denn
wen würden Sie in Deutschland zum
Rücktritt also irgendwen gibt es doch
bestimmt wo sie sagen also der gehört
schon zurückgetreten ja also ich teile
die Auffassung dass politische
Verantwortung zu übernehmen hier in
Deutschland eine andere Kultur hatte ich
formuliert das mal so als als in anderen
Ländern wenn er in England oder im
Vereinigten Königreich schnell
zurückgetreten wird ist ja auch nicht
unbedingt selbstverständlich dann
verdient es aus meiner Sicht auch
Anerkennung dann zu sagen okay hat nicht
gepasst wir schauen mal das Land
ansonsten voranbringen
Verteidigungsministerin mir geht es da
weniger um irgendwelche Fehltritte
sondern ich habe die Beobachtung gemacht
dass da sehr viel ich weiß nicht wie ich
das besser formulieren soll da wird
einfach viel viel politisch rumgeheult
das ist aha und ich habe mein Sohn und
ich habe doch so wenig Zeit und ihr
wollte ich da auch mal dabei haben komm
steh doch einfach dazu was du gemacht
hast als Frau
laber mir doch nicht irgendwas an die
Backe von von wegen auch ich armes
Mäuschen dass das kauft den Leuten
keiner ab oder wenn Robert Habeck sich
ins Fernsehen setzt und erzählt euch ich
weiß ja gar nicht mehr wie so ein
Frühstückstisch aussieht so nach dem
Motto
ja okay also wo sollen wir da jetzt
Mitleid mit den Leuten haben die haben
sich das ausgesucht da zu sitzen also
dass das ist so eine so eine
Herangehensweise die ich nicht verstehe
Robert Habeck wäre für mich eine gute
ein guter Anfang tut mir leid wer sich
wer sich hinsetzt und sagt ja nur weil
Betrieb in Deutschland nicht mehr
produziert heißt ja nicht dass er dann
zwangsläufig insolvent hat
also Insolvenz erklären wollte und was
ist los ist also ein bisschen ungerade
das ist also von einem
Wirtschaftsminister ganz egal von
welcher Partei in welchem Land wer so
einem wirklich einen solchen Unfug
erzählt der sollte sich nach anderer
Arbeit umschauen aber ist es
für sie falsch dieses Sessel kleben
ich weiß nicht ob das ob das eine
typische typisch deutsches Phänomen ist
da habe ich mich zu wenig mit anderen
politischen Systemen im Ausland befasst
ich persönlich habe den Eindruck schon
dass man früher auch in Deutschland
häufiger politische Verantwortung
übernommen hat wenn man sich Fehltritte
geleistet hat aber auf der anderen Seite
muss man auch sagen wo ist da wo ist da
die die Linie ich sehe das ich sehe das
auch kritisch wenn man aus jeder
Kleinigkeit die da ist oder vielleicht
nicht ist
anfängt ein Politikum zu machen ganz
ehrlich da da breche ich dann auch die
Landwehr dann ist er da halt mitgeflogen
also aber es geht dann für mich eher um
die Frage wie die Leute damit umgehen
und wenn die Leute damit nicht souverän
genug umgehen können und da dann so eine
Gerade verfallen
das ist ja tatsächlich da habe ich die
ganze Zeit gedacht das war wirklich so
ein Paradebeispiel wo es auch gar nicht
mal so sehr darum ging glaube ich dass
sie im Urlaub gewesen ist und hat
tatsächlich wie sie danach damit
umgegangen ist in dieser desaströsen
press Konferenz wir glaube ich alle noch
lebhafte in Erinnerung haben da ist doch
klar dass die Vermutung dann sehr nahe
liegt dass so jemand für dieses Amt
nicht geeignet ist das ist es doch ja es
kommt darauf an wie gehst du damit um
wie arbeitest du mit deinen Fehlern das
fehlt mir das stört mich persönlich viel
mehr als dass jemand an seinem Pöstchen
klebt ja das würde ich auch so sehen
damals ist ja beispielsweise Gutenberg
wegen dem Doktortitel zurückgetreten
Herr Gerdemann das ist ja heutzutage
eigentlich schon fast undenkbar dass
jemand nur wegen einem doppelte
zurücktritt oder hat sich das schon was
verändert in den Jahren
ja ich weiß es gar nicht ist ja damals
auch zurückgetreten worden also ob das
so freiwillig war den Kulissen wurde ja
schon stark dazu gedreht ja genau es
gibt ja noch einen anderen Rücktritt ein
unfreiwilligen diese Woche das ja schön
Boom und da frage ich mich wirklich wenn
der ein SPD-Parteibuch gehabt hätte
unter einer SPD Innenministerin Feser
wer denn nicht noch im Amt weil das
haben wir denn da das ist ein
Ex-Unternehmer der in sein Amt gekommen
ist als Chef des BSI
wo Leute so ein bisschen zweifelten an
seiner Qualifikation der sich aber
offenbar ganz gut eingearbeitet hat dann
ordentliches standing hat in der Branche
und dann geht auf irgendeine Party
und deswegen wird im Russen Nähe
vorgeworfen und das reicht um ihn aus
dem Amt zu drängen also das finde ich
irgendwie da ist die Latte dann sehr
niedrig gewesen genau man das ist in
diesem Fall ein Spitzenbeamter
der halt rausgesetzt wurde oder vor die
Tür ges wurde aber wenn das reicht wird
ein Partybesuch relativ harmlose
Partybesuch um einen Spitzenbeamten zu
schaffen
wen wollen wir den dann noch alles
schaffen also es ist
wie ist denn bei ihnen Zeug für sie eine
Rücktritt von Charakterstärke oder eher
von Schwäche es kommt immer auf die
Situation an aber generell würde ich
sagen jemand der Verantwortung übernimmt
der hat meinen Respekt ja und
nichtsdestotrotz gibt es wie Frau
Bosbach schon sagte häufig Hetzjagden wo
jemand gar nicht mehr die Chance bekommt
also fair
nachzuvollziehen was wirklich passiert
dass mir fällt sondern marien ein die
finnische Ministerpräsidentin die auch
aus meiner Sicht gehetzt wurde weil sie
fotografiert wurde auf einer oder Bilder
aus ihrem Amtssitz kam die sie in in
Partylaune zeigten und sie hat dazu
gestanden hat gesagt das war nicht in
Ordnung und ist damit dann auch
durchgekommen und ich fand sie hat
beispielsweise Rückgrat bewiesen hat
auch um Entschuldigung gebeten in einer
ganz anderen Form wie eine Spiegel das
man hat beispielsweise aber ich würde
Ihnen dabei Pflichten man muss
eigentlich wenn Fehler passieren dafür
die Verantwortung übernehmen und dann
kommt es darauf an wie geht jemand mit
den Fehlern um das ist eine spannende
spannende these Hetzjagd der Medien das
ist ja auch zum großen Teil der Job der
Medien zu kontrollieren hier insgesamt
ne also genau nicht nur der Medien aber
die Medien stoßen es oft an heute auch
schon angesprochen dass die Medien dann
natürlich auch wie bei Herr Wolf das ist
eine Frage wie viel ist bei einem
Politiker denn überhaupt noch privat
kaum was ich würde sagen nur die aller
aller Ängste Intimsphäre in deinem Leben
die ist noch privat ansonsten
verschwimmen die Grenzen so massiv das
kann sich keiner vorstellen auch nicht
den Druck der damit einhergeht also es
ist ich wüsste auch nicht ich weiß gar
nicht wie das Menschen wahrnehmen die
nicht so aufgewachsen ist würde mich mal
sehr interessieren ich frag mich ganz
oft so gerade auch so durch diese ganzen
Social Media und so massiv verstärkt
worden ich habe ja auch schon mehr als
Einschätzung erlebt das muss ich kann
damit gut umgehen ich frage mich aber
ganz ganz oft ob ich das auch so gut
wenn ich das nicht alle schon quasi mein
Leben lang mitbekommen hätte darum
wollen sie trotzdem in die Politik sie
haben es ja immer mitbekommen von klein
auf ja warum wollen sie trotzdem in die
Politik ich glaube ich bin mit einem
sehr extrem Gestaltungswillen
ausgestattet gestaltungswellen
ausgestattet worden ich glaube es ist
viel zu kurz zu sagen oder es greift zu
kurz ist einfach eine Tochter aus diesem
Haus ich habe zwei Schwestern die eine
Stewardess die andere hat einen Kaffee
also völlig andere Welten mir kam
natürlich dazu dass ich das Glück hatte
auch mit ihm in der gleichen Stadt mit
meinem Papa in Berlin zu leben und sehr
sehr viel mitbekommen zu dürfen das habe
ich nicht nur fasziniert sondern ich
habe auch gemerkt wie nötig es ist das
tatsächlich so weil die allermeisten
Menschen in meinem Umfeld so wie ich
auch aufgewachsen bin wir sind so auch
sehr Fraktion nicht böse gemeint hier zu
gucken die wir heute eher als sogenannte
burgfraktion bezeichnen würden ja und
ich halt einfach wichtig darüber zu
sprechen was auch was wirklich auch
nachhaltiges Wirtschaften auch bedeutet
gerade für junge Leute dass man sagt
nachhaltigkeit ist auch mehr als
Klimapolitik das geht ja um
Arbeitsplatzsicherheit es geht um
Versorgungssicherheit das sind alles
Themen die mindestens genauso wichtig
sind für die so viel setze ich mich ein
und ich wünsche mir dass sie weiterhin
auch gehört werden auf saboh kommen ja
das ist doch mein schöner Ansatz noch
eine sehr wie soll man sagen
leidenschaftliche Politikerin die noch
davon träumt was zu verändern wir haben
ja auch manchmal welche die nicht mehr
ganz so leidenschaftlich sind deswegen
schön